good morning
welcome to you my listening friend I
hope all is well with you and with your
family this is a special q a session
people send in questions from time to
time and we try to answer to the best of
our ability we've selected some
questions which we will try to answer
hopefully clearly and so enable you to
understand God's word a little more
effectively I have with me Pastor B GoGo
who is a man of God and he will be
asking me the questions and I will try
by the grace of God to answer them so
that you may be blessed welcome my dear
Pastor welcome
Randy and it's indeed a pleasure to be
here to share the word of God
now the first question we have today
we have today is about Judas Iscariot a
brother or a sister out there wonders if
Judas didn't do his part how would the
Plan of Salvation run out because
he if he didn't betray Jesus Christ how
would Jesus then be betrayed and how
would he die for us okay before I answer
that well attempt to answer it let me
pray Father in Heaven Grant to me the
wisdom I need that I may answer
correctly and biblically I pray and
bless those listening please open their
eyes open their minds in Jesus name amen
amen it's an interesting question I've
never heard it before
the Bible did not select Judas to betray
Christ there is a prophecy in Psalm 41
verse 9 yea my own familiar friend in
whom I trusted which did eat of my bread
hath lifted up his heel against me now
Jesus quotes that verse in John 13 Verse
18 when he said you know one of you will
betray me my non-familiar friend hath
littered up his lifted up his heel
against me the Bible did not predict
that Judas would betray Christ the Bible
predicted someone would betray Christ if
it had not been Judas it would have been
somebody else because the scripture
cannot be broken someone had to betray
Christ but judas's name is not in Psalm
41 verse 9 all the psalm tells us is
that someone would betray Christ Judas
chose to be that one
but if he hadn't done it someone would
have done it because the scripture must
be fulfilled when Christ was going into
Jerusalem and the disciples were
shouting and waving palm branches the
Pharisees told Jesus to tell his
disciples to be quiet Jesus said if they
keep quiet the stones would cry out
because something had to be said as a
fulfillment of Prophecy if Judas had not
betrayed Christ someone else would have
because Psalm 41 night predicted someone
would betray Christ Judas chose to be
that person
thank you Pastor prophecy had to be
fulfilled well somebody else has a
question too they wonder they are a new
believer in The Seventh-Day Adventist
Church but they live with someone who
they are helping an 84 year old who's an
Adventist but he plays a music that a as
a young believer he feels it's not
helping him grow in the faith he's
praying about it but he wonders is there
anything else he can do to avoid the
problems he's running into all right
interesting question
the very fact that Believers are in the
world means they are in an environment
that is hostile to their religious
development just by being in this world
the Bible says in Romans 12 verse 18 if
it be possible as much as life in you
live peaceably with all men if you'll
always find yourself in environments
that are hostile to your spirituality
the person can just perhaps get some
headphones listen to sermons on the
headphones and so block out the noise or
simply ask God to enable him or her to
survive that but the person's management
of himself or herself under those
circumstances can be a witness to the
person who's playing the music or
creating the disturbance just the way
you handle something that is adversarial
to you as you judge it to be adversarial
and so I would recommend that the person
do the best he or she can to focus on
the word of God keep the word on the
Mind despite the music the elderly
person maybe play because the Christian
will always find himself whether on the
job in the supermarket on the bus in the
plane where there will be activities
that he or she does not approve of we
will never find a perfect environment
not even in the church and so I advise
that person do the best he or she can
get some headphones listen to servants
listen to Spiritual music but deal with
that situation in a christ-like patient
way because that will be a witness to
the person
so Pastor if I got you right there are
two things you're saying one of them is
understand that God still wants to use
you as a witness in that situation yes
yes and then secondly do it in a manner
that it doesn't affect your spirituality
get your headphones listen to something
that keeps you in the right track you
know when you concentrate very hard it's
amazing what you don't hear
if you concentrate
and so I just suggested a person get
some spiritual material to listen to or
to read and take the matter to God and
see what changes God can make in that
person but in all circumstances Express
a christ-like attitude amen someone else
from Nigeria this time has an
interesting question okay and this is
about prayer he wonders is it okay to
pray with the legere paper it's okay to
pray with alligator paper I had never
heard of alligator pepper until that
question came and we had to check on
YouTube
you pray to God Jesus tells us and the
Bible tells us how to pray
Jesus tells us pray to the father
we read in First John 3 22 and
whatsoever we ask we receive of him
because we keep his Commandments and do
those things which are pleasing in his
sight first John chapter 5 verse 14 and
this is the confidence that we have in
him if we ask anything according to his
will he Hearth us there is nothing
scripturally supportive of praying with
alligator Pepper or any other such thing
we pray in the spirit Romans 8 26 27
because we know not what we should ask
for Romans 8 26 the spirit in us through
the word will enable us to say what we
ought to say and so we pray according to
God's will first John 5 14. we obey God
normally in our lives First John 3 22
Proverbs 28 9 if I regard iniquity in my
heart the Lord will not hear me and so
we make sure our sins are forgiven but
it is absolutely not necessary to pray
with alligator Pepper or alligator
spinach or alligator anything we just
pray to God to the father in the name of
Jesus Christ if he shall ask anything in
my name I will do it John 14 13-14 and
so praying with alligator pepper is
absolutely not necessary that is a
reception and I hope no one will do that
thank you we have somebody else with a
question and also the good thing is is a
young believer who came to understand
about the Sabbath and began to observe
the sabbath recently now in their study
of the book of Exodus they came to a
place where the Bible talks about how to
prepare for Sabbath how to do with your
food and how to go about it so the
question the person has is it okay to
reheat my food on Sabbath yes it's okay
and our our messenger our special
messenger Loy tells us in Child Guidance
page 532 paragraph two it is not
necessary to eat cold food let the food
be warm so warming food is not cooking
food you understand warming food is just
bringing it to temperature where it is
beneficial to the body because food is
too cold is harmful food that's too hot
is harmful and so it can be warm and
that's no violation of the cooking
principles which the Bible forbids
cooking on Sabbath but it's not opposed
to warming the food for the sake of
health so that's fine
thank you very much
on another question somebody is asking
about the close of probation yes and
this goes back to one of your summons
you spoke on the close of Probation and
the question is if God's love is
Everlasting how can the probation be
closed before the life of someone is
over all right interesting question
when before God set the flood
God told Noah Genesis 6 we read from
verse one and it came to pass when men
began to multiply on the face of the
Earth and daughters were born unto them
that the sons of God saw the daughters
of men that they were fair and they took
them wives of always their choice and
the Lord said my spirit shall not always
strive with man whether man corporately
or man individually but his day shall be
120 years Noah preached for 120 years
when that time passed
Noah was ordered by Christ into the ark
and his family Genesis 7 16 says and the
Lord shut him in now when God shut no in
he shut people out the people out were
still alive they weren't dead but the
opportunity to be saved was passed their
probation had closed when that door was
shut notice the Bible doesn't say Noah
shut the door the Bible says the Lord
shut him in either an angel or God
himself shut that door symbolically
bringing an empty any opportunity the
others had to be saved and so probation
does exist God is loving but God has
limits
on his tolerance of sin God told the
Jewish Nation 78 years are determined
upon thy people of 70 days which is
symbolically seven uh 70 days 70 years
490 years he began in 457 BC it ended in
a34 then the lord gave up on the Jewish
Nation as a nation not on individuals
but as a chosen Nation politically
representing him on this Earth probation
does close for people
that is why when the angel or whomever
shut that door from above those on the
outside that was it they had no more
opportunity to be saved and if God is
always loving yes
but we know that this world will perish
Revelation 21 1 I saw a new Heaven and
in the earth when God has had it up to
here with this new this world and this
this contaminated Heaven he will come
and destroy this Earth destroy this
heaven and make a brand new Earth and a
brand new heaven God will not tolerate
sin forever just because he's loving it
is as much an act of Love on God's part
to destroy his sin and sinners as it is
to save those who come to him the is
probation no one is given Limitless time
to sin we have a certain amount of time
and when that time passes that's it and
that is dramatically demonstrated in the
story of the flood when God closed that
door and those on the outside lost and
by the way when God closed the door
seven days passed before the rain came
so they were in there
and do outside of the Ark those in the
ACT were probably wondering will the
rain come those on the side were
probably wondering the same thing seven
days passed and the people outside were
probably laughing themselves to death
them the rain came they probably knocked
on the door but nothing happened in the
parable of the ten virgins five wise
five foolish when the five foolish ran
and finally got all and they came back
the door was shut and the bridegroom
said I don't know you their probation
had passed there was no more opportunity
to enter that ceremony representing
Christ receiving his bride for the
church probation is biblical let me say
to those watching and listening today is
the best time to give your life to
Christ do not assume you have 50 years
because you're 17 or you have 20 years
because you're 50 you have today God
does not give us a receipt for tomorrow
we have today make that decision for God
today
if you hear his voice right today is
your day hard not your heart thank you
president that's all we have today and I
believe we would encourage our audience
yes and more questions yes if you have
questions now let me say very honestly
we will not answer every single question
but we will pray and based on conviction
we will select some questions and try to
answer them do not give up the privilege
of studying the Bible for yourselves
John 16 verse 13 Jesus said how be it
when he the spirit of Truth has come he
will guide you into all truth it is one
of the responsibilities of the spirit of
God to teach those who sincerely come to
the word seeking answers make an attempt
to study the word for yourself when the
Pharisees ask Jesus in Matthew 19 Verse
3 is it lawful for a man to put away his
wife for every cause Jesus said in verse
4 have we not read that he which made
them at the beginning made them male
female notice the words of Christ have
ye not read haven't you studied haven't
you read the word and so I urge you
study ask the spirit to help you you may
be surprised and shocked how the spirit
of God will guide you into truth may the
Lord bless you as you study his word and
by his grace obey what the word reveals
to you thank you very much my pastor and
God bless you abundantly thank you first
of blessings you're welcome my friends
we'll see you the next time